we're on the brink of war with China for
various reasons I hope we make it to
2050. one word that has caught
everyone's attention this year is
inflation First Republic will now be
taken over by JP Morgan That's the bid
that the FDIC has accepted jurors in the
civil lawsuit against Donald Trump have
found the former U.S president not
guilty of raping magazine columnist e
Gene Carroll for decades the U.S dollar
has been King on the global stage but a
growing number of mostly Emerging Market
countries are pushing for a change
saying they want to de-dollarize their
economies
if you feel like there's this ever
looming mood of pessimism in the era if
you have this gut feeling that men
America kind of feels like it's rotting
from within right now it's because it is
and it's all happening according to plan
but America is not collapsing because of
some conspiracy no America is set to
collapse in around 35 years give or take
according to Ray Daly's predictions
because of one thing and one thing only
good old human nature and Ray dalio Mata
all out for us
stay dangerous and this is the gradual
fall of the American Empire
[Music]
foreign
in times like these it's easy to be
pessimistic but in actuality you should
be very excited that's because according
to Forbes most millionaires have been
made during times of Market chaos just
like right now in fact five of the
world's richest investors made their
fortunes during the 2008 financial
crisis one factor as to why is because
they had access to markets most of us
Overlook and the same thing is happening
right now and one market the masses are
really overlooking right now is the Art
Market the Art Market is the only Market
to go up in the past year besides energy
stocks and the last time inflation was
above three percent like it is right now
Contemporary Art appreciated by an
average of 20 Blue Chip our prices have
even outpaced the S P 500 by 131 since
1995. according to City the problem is
it takes a lot of money to buy a single
piece of Arts but luckily that is where
our sponsor Masterworks comes in
Masterworks offers fractional shares of
art from Legends like Picasso Banksy and
Monet two-day Masterworks has sold over
45 million dollars worth of artwork and
distributed the net proceeds to
investors which in today's economic
climate should explain why over 700 000
people have signed up so far demand is
growing by the day but you guys can skip
the waitlist by clicking the link in the
description so pause the video and click
the link below to sign up for
Masterworks now
foreign
[Music]
I went back and I needed to study the
Cycles these what's happened over longer
periods of time so I studied the last
500 years because these big Cycles take
about 75 years and give or take about
50. in this big cycle a country becomes
wealthy and Powerful Peaks and then
suddenly Falls from its position and
soon another Empire takes a spot at the
top it happened to the Dutch the British
and now it's happening to America and
here's how it works
to get to the top a country needs a
combination of a few things low debt
small gas and wealth values and politics
a productive population education and
really good leadership if a country has
all these things it will become more
productive it will make more stuff make
more money it's people will start new
businesses and trade more its
infrastructure develops and therefore it
becomes richer but here's the key the
more the country trades with everyone
else the more every other country would
need its currency to pay for its stuff
so every other country around the world
will start saving that currency for
trade and once everyone starts using and
saving that currency it becomes the
global reserve and from there there's
nowhere to go but up a countries whose
currency is the global Reserve can
borrow more they can print more money
without worrying about inflation and
they can use all that freshly printed
cash to develop their infrastructure
military and economy faster than
everyone else and eventually the country
will reach its peak
uh it's Pete the country enjoys all the
perks of being the world's strongest
superpower it can enslave other
countries it can colonize other
countries for resources it can build
massive cities and invest in technology
and can go to war with anyone who
doesn't do what it wants and it enjoys
plenty of wealth and economic
opportunities but Prosperity is a
double-edged sword on one hand you
finally get to reap what you sow you
finally get to enjoy all the fruits of
your labor but on the other hand you are
comfortable now there's no more struggle
your kids get more comfortable and all
those productive habits that made you
great you start to relax on them a
little bit more instead of growing the
economy and innovating like you used to
you become less competitive you start to
sit back and enjoy life a little bit
more you no longer live to work but you
work to live I'm looking at you Europe
and so these Good Times create weak men
and once these weak men stop being
productive and Innovative the Empire is
guaranteed to eventually fall everyone
is less productive they get caught up
finding pointless political battles and
so that the client hits them suddenly
they have to go into debt to keep up
their trade and production suddenly
people are finding it hard to get jobs
or start new businesses bureaucracy
starts to pile up regulations start to
pile up while other countries are
silently rising up to challenge them
every single great Empire over the past
500 years has gone through this exact
big cycle they followed the exact same
blueprint and one of the first modern
Empires to go through this was the
Netherlands
[Music]
in 1581 the Netherlands gained
independence from the Spanish monarchy
and so for the first time the
hard-working intelligent open-minded
Dutch people had a chance to work for
themselves instead of for the Spaniards
so during the next 44 years the Dutch
established an Empire more powerful than
anyone had ever seen before it they
built ships that could travel the world
to trade which made their owners
insanely rich and from that they created
the world's first ever Mega Corporation
the Dutch East India Company the Dutch
East India Company brought products from
all over India back to the Netherlands
so they could sell it to their neighbors
the Dutch even went on to Pioneer
capitalism as we know it today where
instead of one person taking on all the
risk to pay for the ships people could
buy shares in the shipping company and
all benefit from its future profits and
soon companies all over the country were
offering the same thing and since
smaller individuals could invest in
bigger companies this made everyone
richer and since they were the ones
Trading with the world the most the
world had to save and use the Dutch's
currency the Dutch guilder so the Dutch
guilder became the world's first Reserve
currency and from there the Dutch Empire
just kept going up Amsterdam became the
world's major financial center and at
the time the Dutch East India Company
was richer than Apple Google and
Facebook combined but like clockwork
what comes up must eventually come down
eventually the Dutch started focusing
more on spending their money and
enjoying it rather than using it to
invest in the future at the same time
other countries like the UK were
starting to get more powerful and the
British East India Company became one of
their biggest competitors but the Dutch
didn't care they were on top of the
world there was no chance anyone was
going to topple them much unless the
pathetic British which sounds a lot like
the rhetoric we're hearing today
downplaying China but then the
Industrial Revolution came around and
while the UK was busy growing its
factories and boosting trade the
Netherlands got complacence England
started taking over their markets and
the Netherlands started going deep into
debts on top of that they also got into
a bunch of small expensive Wars that
drained their resources and money and
then the final straw the bank of
Amsterdam kept printing more money than
it had in gold or silver in reserve
leading to one of the first ever Bank
runs this destroyed people's faith in
the Dutch currency people didn't want
the paper Dutch guilder anymore they
wanted gold silver medals that they knew
wouldn't lose their value if the Gilder
became worthless and that was the final
nail in the coffin the Netherlands time
as the world's first real superpower
came to an end today the Netherlands is
a sad shell of its former self it's but
a teeny tiny country in Europe known for
its wheat coffee shop psychedelic
mushroom stores red light district and a
little bit of Dutch kickboxing a far cry
from the vast Empire it once was and
don't get me wrong it's a genuinely fun
place to visit with incredibly kind
people but oh have the mighty have
fallen and what the fall of the Dutch it
gave rise to an even greater Empire the
British
foreign
where the Dutch had his ships the
British had the Industrial Revolution
while the Dutch were struggling to stay
competitive the British were busy
cranking up their factories Rich were
the growing Navy that was giving the
Dutch a run for their money Britain was
in the perfect position to take the
throne and then came the war with
Napoleon using both financial and
physical Warfare Britain managed to
defeat France and Napoleon in the early
1800s it was the one brynden needed to
force its way to the top and with all
this new money from trade and
industrialization Britain quickly built
a massive Fleet of ships to travel and
exploit all its colonies around the
world see Britain have been colonizing
the world since the 1600s but it wasn't
until they had fast enough ships that
the British really started making money
from its colonies and make money they
did the British took an estimated 45
trillion dollars of wealth from India
alone just India that's almost double
America's entire GDP now imagine all the
money they made from Britain's other 56
colonies around the world
gold diamonds Ivory and Khan from Africa
they took splice's money material teas
and other resources from India basically
anything they could sell to their
European neighbors they took by 1850
Brynn was responsible for around 40 of
all the exports in the world and because
they only accepted British pounds in
exchange for their goods the pound
became the world's new Reserve currency
the British kept getting richer and
richer London became the world's
financial center and it looked like the
British were Untouchable just like how
America looks today but by the late
1800s Britain's power and influence
Peaks when World War One Hit Britain
spent billions of pounds to help its
Allies win on top of that for four years
most of Britain's trained in export
stalled instead of collecting resources
from around the world they were handing
resources out while its Navy was busy
finding an expensive War a war that
would put Britain in a lot of foreign
debts and even though the Allies
eventually won it came at a massive
price the Great depression for 10 years
Bryn's economy slumps trade was down the
country was in debts and the people were
too poor and discouraged to even think
about Innovation it would take more than
15 years after World War one for Bryn's
economy to finally start picking up
again in the late 1930s right in time
for World War II
[Music]
[Applause]
as your plunge into war most of
America's European allies sent their go
to America for safekeeping they didn't
want the Germans to get their hands on
it as World War II came to a close
Europe wasn't ruined everyone was in
debt their economies had been decimated
so the Allies needed to come together to
reset the deck to create a new world
financial order so they gathered at the
Bretton Woods conference in 1944. at
Bretton Woods New Hampshire delegates
from 44 Allied and Associate countries
arrived for the opening of the United
Nations monetary and financial
conference
since America had all the gold and
America wasn't in Ruins America had all
the bargaining power so America's strong
armed the world into a deal a deal where
America will continue hanging on to all
the gold and the American dollar will be
picked to the gold everyone around the
world would now use dollars and the
dollars would be as good as gold at the
time the deal probably made sense and
it's not like that other countries
really had a choice so everyone accepted
and just like that the British pound was
out and the dollar was in and with the
dollar as the global reserve it didn't
take long for the US to figure out that
they could secretly print billions of
dollars behind everyone's backs to spend
on their military and social programs
and no one would even notice and so
started America's decade of prosperity
America now had an infinite amount of
money to invest in its growth which was
an advantage that no other country had
all because it claimed that title of the
world's Reserve currency and like the
British and the Dutch America also had
its own colonies around the world to
exploit except instead of colonizing
them with a giant Navy America colonized
them through deaths which allowed
America to scale up their empire faster
and wider than anyone before it which
brings us to today
we're back with some breaking news this
morning First Republic Bank has been
taken over by federal Regulators they're
still projecting a recession we're back
now with the breaking news the January
inflation report just out this morning
shows the Consumer Price Index Rose
about half a percent in January NBC News
has learned a New York Grand Jury has
just voted to indict former president
Donald Trump earlier today just a few
blocks away there was looting underway
nearby police seem to have had enough
the housing market is crashing it is the
world now going through the long
predictive process of de-dollarization
thank you
[Music]
according to Ray dalio one an Empire is
on the decline eight main factors start
to decline in this predictable order
first the education of the country
starts to fall then the country starts
to get less competitive then Innovation
and Technology starts to go on the
decline then trade Falls its Financial
Center starts to fall out of favor then
the country's economic output declines
then the military starts to finally go
down and finally the last nail in the
coffin that marks the end of an Empire
is when it loses its Reserve currency
status and for America we're witnessing
this happening right now in this exact
order first it was education we can all
agree that American education has not
been all that good as far back as 2013
International rankings labeled the U.S
education system mediocre when compared
to countries like China Korea or even
Finland at the same time America's
competitiveness has did too nothing is
made in America anymore it's too
expensive which was okay when we were at
the top of technology and Innovation but
now we're even slipping on that front
too and next on The Chopping Block is
trade in 2021 China Germany and Russia
had the world's biggest trade surpluses
while America had the world's biggest
trade deficit meaning that America
imported far more than exported so out
of the eight factors Ray dalio outlands
America is already declining in the
first four which means next up we can
expect New York to start to fall out of
favor as the world's Financial Center
which isn't too hard to imagine because
New York banks are already moving to
places like Florida after New York Falls
all favor we can expect America's
economic output to start to decline
China's GDP is already set to pass
America's by 2035 you can even see it
very clearly in this graph
the United States has a lot of debt and
it has deficits so it has to sell debt
now if you say and others are holding
debt and if you say how do you get
healthy you have to spend less than you
earn to get to not borrow money and get
financially strong so we're living in a
world now where policy makers don't
think how much money do I have to spend
and what should I prioritize it on they
think how much money do I need to spend
without regard to how much they have and
then they go spend it and then they have
deficits at central banks can print it's
just like the same as individuals they
have the deficit but in their case they
have the capacity to print the money to
pay the deficit so I think you're in the
part of the cycle where you've had the
tightening and then the dominoes are
beginning to fall and once America's
economic output starts to decline
America's military will decline next
this is probably the hardest to imagine
right now being America's military is
far ahead of everyone including Russia
and China but once that happens you can
guarantee that the Dollar's position as
the global Reserve is going to be on the
chopping block next every single Global
Reserve currency has fallen in the past
and we're already seeing a small but
strong anti-dollar movement growing and
if that happens if America loses its
Reserve currency status all hell will
break loose here in America all the
dollars held by other countries right
now will flow right back into America
which will make the inflation we're
seeing today look like a walk in the
park it will be Financial Armageddon for
Americans the only question is how long
do we have according to Ray dalio the US
is roughly 70 through its big cycle plus
or minus 10 so if we assume the big
cycle starter at around the end of World
War II that means we have around 35
years left give or take but what do you
think will America eventually fall and
if so when and how would you even
prepare for a once in a lifetime event
like this well no one can really say for
sure but half the battle is you want to
make as much money as you can right now
and the other half of the battle is
putting your money into other currencies
or into real assets that will still be
valuable if and when the dollar goes
down things like businesses real estate
crypto but most importantly you got to
be investing in yourself obviously
regardless if America crumbles or not
and if you are starting from zero and
you want some help making more money
then you might want to take the route
that I took when I was first getting
started see back when I was 19 I was
just this awkward kid in community
college that didn't have a degree and
had hardly any experience but I really
really wanted to make money online so I
tried everything graphic design stock
trading and so on but as a teenager
without any experience obviously those
business ideas didn't work so I thought
I might as well try Landing a work from
home job to hold me over I was reading a
lot of marketing and psychology books at
the time and that's when it hit me I
realized that applying for jobs is not
about how much experience you have on
paper no it's about how good you are at
marketing yourself my theory was that if
I marketed myself well I can maybe beat
the boring application with a lot more
experience so I went ham applying all
the marketing and psychology principles
I was learning into my job application
and it worked I remember being on a
family trip with my parents and my phone
was blowing up with companies hitting me
up and one of them ended up hiring me
for a 40 per hour work from home job at
only 19 years old without a degree and
hardly any experience to put that into
context that's around eighty thousand
dollars a year at full time hours at 19
years old and this job changed my entire
life I was able to drop off College I
made a ton of money all while having the
time to work on what would become this
YouTube channel and because work from
home jobs changed my life forever I
decided to take this framework that I
developed and I put it into a master
class so you too can lend a work from
home job without a degree even if you're
starting from zero like I was this is
the best course out there on how to get
a work from home job because not only
has it worked for me but it's worth for
our other students long story short one
of them landed a 25 per hour position
living in South Africa and another
landed on the same position where he got
equity in the company the company got
Acquired and he made Bank from the stock
going up so if this sounds interesting
to you and you want to learn more click
the square on the screen to watch our
quick video explaining it click the
square on the screen to watch now
foreign
[Music]